we want this thing to end we don't want
a lot of people getting infected we want
it to end and then Daz quickly as
possible so far I think we've done a
fantastic job I really think that the
people behind me have not been given the
credit that they deserve as president
Trump in the last hour talking about his
administration's work to fight the
corona virus had a news conference in
the White House
this of course comes after the
administration lawmakers struck a
late-night deal last night a new
measures to curb the pandemic including
free testing and paid lis programs the
White House also adding restrictions
within its own walls saying temperature
checks will be conducted for those who
are in close contact with both the
President and a vice president that out
of an abundance of caution President
Trump saying yes he has tested for the
corona virus but does not yet have the
result though he says he's feeling fine
Jeff Mason joins us White House reporter
for Reuters veteran of the White House
Jeff were you over there this afternoon
did you get tested what have you heard
from some of your colleagues I was not
there this afternoon I was there
yesterday for the the press conference
in the Rose Garden and today I was in
touch with my colleague who was there
and they did temperature checks for all
the reporters who were in the briefing
room with a thermometer swap basically
along the forehead and then made clear
that that wasn't just for journalists
but for anybody else who was going to be
in close contact with with vice
president pence and with President Trump
that is a new measure and I think it
signals a new seriousness with which
this White House is taking the potential
for this virus to spread not only among
the public but there at the White House
and there among the people with whom the
president and his staff are interacting
and talk about that new seriousness also
in terms of policy in terms of the
bipartisan legislation that was passed
last night even though 40 Republicans to
vote against it
billions of dollars billions to try and
fight the pandemic and also to reassure
Americans absolutely and you heard
Treasury Secretary Stephen venusian at
that White House briefing this afternoon
saying that this is just the first step
so it also shows as you rightly say a
sign of the seriousness with which they
are taking it in terms of policy both
Democrats and Republicans this of course
a
was the result of negotiations between
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi and Stephen
Venusian I guess it sounds like most of
the day yesterday and the last several
days and more to come so they clearly
are cognizant now it may have some
critics may say it took a little bit too
long of both the economic and the health
impacts of this virus and are taking
steps now at a at a time when hopefully
they can reduce that curve that dr.
Anthony Fauci has been talking about in
terms of the virus and the impact it
yeah if they don't reduce that curve I
mean just before this happened the CDC
had these alarming numbers 21 million
hospitalized yeah we have nine hundred
twenty-five thousand beds 162 214
million over 70% of Americans possibly
and could be infected 200,000 to 1.7
million deaths this is all now aimed at
trying as you say flatten that curb and
we have something else that being
flattened and that's some of the
decisiveness in Washington here's the
vice president talking about the new
bipartisanship and I want to join
President Trump in thanking Speaker
Pelosi a leader McCarthy the Republicans
and Democrats in the House of
Representatives who as the president
said earlier today pulled together
pulled together to pass legislation
that's meeting this moment in the
bipartisan health first spirit that the
American people would expect do you
think something this this is caused
something not a change in Washington
well it's a great question I think time
will tell it certainly hasn't
necessarily been that way the last few
weeks the president when when calling
for bipartisanship has also been very
critical of Vice President Biden who may
end up being his competitor in the
general election and former President
Obama and so we'll see if his if his
rhetoric changes certainly he talked
today about habits changing he got a
little bit of criticism yesterday at
that Rose Garden press conference for
shaking hands with some of the CEOs who
were there and he was asked about that
this afternoon and he basically just
said look it's a habit but he agreed
when he's when he was asked about and
said it's probably not a good
idea to shake hands and so whether those
habits applied just to that kind of
interpersonal reaction but also to
tweeting and you know attitudes yeah not
just from the White House from Democrats
as well yeah is something that we'll
just have to watch in the in the coming
days and weeks yeah no matter what comes
out of the mouse we should start off so
doing the old elbow bumps or you know
just going like this or maybe not even
fist bumps I don't know what I guess no
fizz nose fist bumps okay or else
there's no fist bumps yeah I think
either elbow elbow bumps or just an odd
seems to be the the safest way going
forward we'll have that and I will nod
to you Jeff nation until you sir even by
satellite in a different city good to
see you and say thanks